wir müssen uns einer impfpflicht nähern
sagt karl lauterbach im gespräch mit
paul ronzheimer es war mal einhellige
meinung die impfpflicht wird nicht
kommen das wäre alles lustig wenn es
nicht so ernst wäre peter er stand da
und auch bis vor ein paar tagen auf der
homepage der bundesregierung unter so
eine frage antworten stück wo über fake
news aufgeklärt worden ist zu einer
impfung opel und stand unter anderem
kommt ein kommt eine impfpflicht nein
also eine fehlermeldung das hat man
entfernt nach dem beschluss der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz bei dass
offensichtlich das tor aufgemacht man
für einen endlich dazu kann man stehen
wie man will es gibt unterschiedliche
ansichten es ist nur immer problematisch
wenn das vorher ausschließt und dann
plötzlich doch ins spiel bringt bringst
was kommen wird ich weiß nicht ob die
totale impfpflicht kommen wird aber was
kommen wird ist eine impfpflicht für
bestimmte einrichtungen also dass zum
beispiel putzfrauen und pfleger die
kontakte zu leuten die sich gleich
jahren können bei einfach nicht
wegrennen können die kassen pflegebett
wegrennen das sagen die impfpflicht
kommt und dies auch vernünftig
jetzt mit dem finger nur auf die
ungeimpften zu zeigen finde ich
merkwürdig ich finde das gehört sich
nicht aufwendig völliges unverständnis
haben für leute die sich nicht impfen
lassen aber die an pranger zu stellen es
ist ein freies land das ist eine freie
entscheidung die muss mir nicht gefallen
ich kann alles versuchen dass und wie zu
ändern aber offensichtlich haben im
gesamten deutschsprachigen raum ein
problem wir erreichen nicht gehen nicht
genügend war das betrifft nicht nur
ostdeutschland oder südostdeutschland
sondern dass das betrifft ja auch
österreich und die schweiz auch so auch
lothar wieler chefs hat alarm geschlagen
wir schauen einmal rein in ein zitat von
ihm er hat ja auch vergangene woche ganz
klar gesagt es ist fünf nach zwölf also
er hat die lage derzeit in deutschland
ist sehr dramatisch bezeichnet und das
heißt er über eine drohende impfpflicht
die impfpflicht ist ein mittel da bin
ich ganz bei der
weltgesundheitsorganisation dass wir
alle nicht wollen es ist wirklich
niemand der eine impfpflicht haben
möchte aber wenn man alles andere
versucht hat dann sagt die whu dann muss
man auch über eine impfpflicht
nachdenken also offenbar hat er den
eindruck wir sind langsam am ende
angekommen wo wir alles versucht haben
und dass das fast unausweichlich ist
peter haben alles versucht gibt es noch
also außer dass wir jeden der sich jetzt
noch impfen ist 5000 euro geben glaube
ich ist so gut wie alles versucht worden
es gibt einfach leute die sind nicht
erreichbar da dafür die christ und nicht
geben denn das was er in belgien oder
dann sehen die gehen dann auch oft sich
auf die straße sind so gut sind die dann
auch radikal du wirst ein paar leute
kriegen aber dadurch sehen nicht alle
kriegen und ich glaube nicht dass es
ausreicht für die herren immunität und
das was professor wie gesagt das ist
nicht das ist vor allem angst getrieben
vor dem nächsten jahr und von init und
dem jahr drauf wenn wir also nicht
genügend im viel kriegen wenn wir das
nicht schaffen dann kommt das diesen
kreislauf nicht wie ich daraus auch mit
drohenden londons oder mit bestimmten
schließung dann kriegen wir die masken
vom gesicht und das ist das problem wir
müssen irgendwann mal erreichen dass
genug leute entweder geimpft oder
immunisiert sind und immunisiert heißt
dann also wenn du dich gegen sind
analysiert einmal erkrankt waren und
dann hohe antikörper haben und dass das
dann vielleicht wird für ein halbes 34
dreivierteljahr aber das heißt auch
viele leute die sich die erkrankten sind
auch viele tote meer und das will man
natürlich vermeiden dass es aufgabe von
medizin dass es aufgabe von politik zu
versuchen tote zu vermeiden wir sind auf
der anderen seite aber nicht zwingend
die pflicht von politik eine impfpflicht
einzuführen da mag man persönlich dann
auch dafür sein mag man vielleicht haben
wir haben bei masern impfung wären bei
anderen sachen auch eine impfpflicht
aber da ist niemals versprochen dass
diese pflicht nicht kommen wird das ist
das problem die würde hat sich die
politik selbst gestellt